bottom to this video playing Grand
Master Jasper Jasper last card song ok
that's a Swedish gem and he's a
specialist list of the stone wall so the
stone wall let's see I mean he really
knows this opening in an odd ok not
going for it yeah maybe ok you sometimes
you can start with that and still go for
the stone wall but it doesn't look like
he's going to do that yeah seems he's
playing for an e5 based set up
interesting
hmm yeah if I am he wants to go he five
playing with the idea to take a plane
95-year you playing on the D file maybe
not great but we're going to see what
happens nights if he wants to strengthen
the e5 ideas to play a night move like
this happen looks awkward he still plays
it yeah it looks awkward maybe it's not
not that bad give up if I've night edge
for this kind of thing is what I'm
thinking about not clear that is this
really leading to much night b5 is also
move as weird as it looks doesn't have a
clear defenseless pawn or very let's say
obvious one what about I can go Quincy
to actually that's a good move that's a
good move if i if i take i just take the
porn i guess when I 5 or not i think i
can take it if i take the pond and if
you cannot play you Fife is kind of
without of ideas almost ok he insists on
this idea but ok h3 night age six system
right
okay efore f4e five curious mmm
sometimes this is possible in the also
in them in the classical variation of
the Dutch but I don't know well okay I
don't want to spend an hour here if I go
g45 okay that is actually interesting uh
navi after a five i have the move c5
it's very necessary otherwise this is a
rotten structure okay so we prepared
five I still have c5 and so I am going
to prepare that even more maybe ok
that's ok that's ok move I'm I'm ready
for this and I have to my advantage she
have or let's say not my advantage but
the the positive side of my position is
the better piece mobilization of the
rukon t1 and he's kind of stuck here in
the back and I want to open up the
position as quickly as possible and this
is probably happening now on 95 95 yes
and takes on takes here right yeah c6 I
thought like e6 maybe yeah that's okay
oh he's allowing he's allowing some
discoveries here maybe yeah because of
the move f 3 which is funny okay let's
stake here let's take that first I can
take a 4-1 Knight b6 night be 64 the
rook but the Queen will move and here's
f3 coming
okay now what I going to do after Quincy
three I'm badly behind all the clock it
didn't feel like I was playing that
slowly but it seems I did yeah okay
let's get gets it gets tricky now with
that note I'm Queen g-form Queen e5f
three Queens III yeah I would have
really liked to have more time here but
what can you do I have night III as well
I am I don't need to give up the piece
necessarily just got this week back rank
I don't know I don't know why don't they
cannot calculate this shop f3 the week
back rank and this I actually can
calculate let's just a piece therefore
you can take you for awesome pawns it's
not totally clear
okay that's nice kind of i'm pretty
consolidated here time morning yes
bishop is a great defender group the a
takes takes chick
yeah oh look that move quite obviously
but get some more stuff traded
check Oh what am i doing you ah what oh
okay yeah that's a way to win a game
buddy wow what a joke okay I'm resigning
white rook me one rupee one okay what
can you do it yeah it's kind of fit
that's not really nice 22 notes like
that you're just a piece up for nothing
Andrew key one I don't know I simply
didn't see that and that doesn't happen
that often this kind of one mover it's
just a piece for nothing and the the bad
thing is that he was totally outplayed
him that's really the case I'm getting
flack for this again I know the day that
I'm kind of bashing the opponent but you
really played the really really bad game
year after c5 black is falling apart
it's just like that okay takes 95 t5 and
that's it basically you know night f4 is
also good but the Queen c3 looks fine he
has nothing out simply he has no nothing
developed and I'm totally centralized
the relatively best according to the
engine is this move then he five is
excellent Jerry okay after that age for
white just wins or not lesyk is the comp
finding something Queens you form at the
compass giving f3s even more precise f3
Queen here and 97 well as a as a
complete win plus two mm-hmm okay so I
could have played even better
this is this is pretty convincing right
I mean it's really just a piece almost
yeah it's really just a piece yeah it's
useless it's just it's just a complete
win an important thing is about is
opening I mean you just played I don't
know what all those moves here if that
it's very important that white here must
be ready to to counter a five you played
night of seven here but let's say you
place a high of it is very important
strategically that why does not what
shouldn't play a slow move here like
let's say D Phi this is this is really
bad now because the center is closed and
black has ideas to play against this
weekend structure here so I have to to
break it up and it's just with that move
that is just wrong as this is why I went
through to you one end stuff you have to
prepare it to prepare that it also night
if I with the temple here black is in a
bad shape simply because the center will
be a will be opened up and black is in
no position for that yeah the night is
on age six and he has he doesn't have
his route connect looks connected and so
on it's just a big ol mess the what he
did was relatively relatively better the
thing what you can do is you can
actually argue if before is necessary
but I wanted to play I didn't expect him
to play you five because this is after
c5 yeah it's just bad but I thought I
wanted to play c5 immediately anyway
let's say I thought you might play I
know be six or so it's better than he
five then it's it's an open question
what I do it's not not clear if I've is
just um ya doing doing what I want and
yeah just should blunder look right okay
thanks for watching